hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll we
talk about a lot of different topics
here on mindscape from wine to the
origin of the universe
but there's one thing that they all have
in common that when we talk about them
we are using language to do the talking
you are hearing me speak words usually
with a guest also speaking words forming
sentences and so forth the structure of
language is very basic to how we
communicate about the world and it's
also basic to how we think about the
world and how we perceive it there's a
famous hypothesis the sapir-warf
hypothesis
in linguistics that says that the way
that we shape the way that we think
about the world is only through language
you sort of cannot perceive things that
you don't have the language for
now admittedly this is not exactly true
you know we've actually talked about
this on the podcast before and we know
that there's more to it than that but
there's something true about it the
existence of concepts in our vocabulary
helps us access the world in a very
direct way in fact it's a kind of coarse
graining which we've talked about in the
context of statistical mechanics and
also a kind of emergence in a sense
because
the world is really really complicated
there's a lot of things going on out
there and yet when we talk about it when
we both think about it internally and
also express it to other people we have
a finite number of vocabulary words with
which we can do that sometimes we're
straining to find the right word but
sometimes certain words just don't exist
the number of colors for example that a
human being can perceive as we talked
about with ed yong very recently is very
large but the number of words for colors
is relatively small so what is it that
lets us choose exactly which words
should exist what are the processes by
which we evolve into a language
structure that lets us describe the
world in a way that is both efficient
but also good enough for the purposes
that we have today's guest nick enfield
is a linguistic anthropologist who's
thought a lot about the origin of
languages but also about the purpose you
know it's not just well this language
grew up in this region but
why did that language grow up what were
the reasons that were in that moment
really really useful to the people who
were inventing these ideas of languages
and as you might expect upon a moment's
reflection a perfectly scientifically
rigorous way of thinking about the world
is not necessarily the only motivation
we have so the natural tools were given
to describe the world in terms of
language are not necessarily optimized
for scientific rigor and accuracy what
are they optimized for well let me just
say that nick's new book is called
language versus reality why language is
good for lawyers and bad for scientists
the idea being that a major reason why
language was first invented is not for
description but for persuasion for
trying to get some social cooperation
either an individual to do something
with you or a group of people to go
along with something that's not
necessarily bad that's an important
feature of social life as a
communicating animal that's what
language is really for ultimately but
then we repurpose it for scientific
purposes and this is science in the
broadest possible sense of the word
trying to understand the world in an
accurate way so what that means is that
this tool that we have for talking to
each other about the world isn't really
meant for talking about the world in an
unbiased way that has really interesting
implications for how to think about
language how to be careful not to be
falling into traps of bias and
oversimplification and so forth and also
maybe how to use it better as we learn
more about it so this is both
interesting intrinsically as a study of
linguistics and how language is used and
also as a practical matter how to think
about the world in a more precise way if
our goal is more scientific not to
mention if our goal is to persuade
people to go along with us so let's go
[Music]
nick enfield welcome to the mindscape
podcast
thanks very much for having me
we're going to talk a lot about how
language is used you have this fantastic
subtitle uh on your book about how
language is great for lawyers and
terrible for scientists so that's just
you know candy for someone like me we
have to talk about that but let's start
with something that is not directly what
you talk about but important which is
the origin of language this is something
people have talked about a lot maybe we
don't know
that much i mean what do we know about
how language got started
well there's been a great deal of
activity in the last few decades
famously
there was a long time ban on talking
about the evolution of language uh you
know within linguistics anyway because
it was regarded as being
overly speculative
but in
recent decades i'd say since
the 90s especially uh there's been an
enormous amount of attention being paid
to
the question and amazing
advances in
new data to do with the evolution of
humans and
you know the vocal apparatus um
a lot of advances in thinking and also
computational techniques for for
modeling hypotheses about language
evolution and
uh a lot that's gone on and you know
there's a whole
society for studying language evolution
and you know they now have a massive
conference every year and so it's a it's
a very lively field there
is of course as you would expect in a
field like that not
a huge amount of
uh consensus you know there are some
really quite
different ideas about kind of what what
are the important puzzles to solve but
language is just this incredibly
multifaceted phenomenon so
uh
there's there's a whole lot to talk
about but from my point of view what i
think is
most important about that question is
the
kind of cognition that is
a prerequisite for the evolution of
language and so i'm in the
camp of researchers like mike tomasello
and steve levenson
in the cognitive sciences who
have emphasized well rob and dunbar too
for that matter um
who've emphasized
that social cognition
is really crucial and prior to that the
emphasis was more on
how we process information and sort of
you know logical operations like
recursion and these things are
important but
i think what we've learned
in recent years is that that social
cognition social coordination so-called
theory of mind
these are really crucial prerequisites
for language
well you mentioned something we talked
about the evolution that i've always
been impressed with when i hear people
talk about it which is the sort of give
and take between our physical biological
evolution and the evolution of language
right i think that there's a
metaphor that a lot of modern people
will have whereby
language is more like software and our
bodies are more like hardware and those
are just different things but clearly
well clearly the biological evolution
has influenced the evolution of language
and maybe even the other way around
yeah i i think
i mean the first thing to really
emphasize is that
when we talk about the evolution of
language there are two really very
different evolutionary tracks and and
one of them is the
biological development of the human
species
the fact that we're different from other
species and
the fact that you can take a
newborn from anywhere in the world and
put them anywhere else in the world and
they'll acquire the language that's
being spoken around them so there's
something in our
biology that makes it possible for us to
acquire language
there's a lot of discussion around what
that is
but that is entirely different from
another evolutionary track of language
which is
the historical evolution of individual
languages
and
you know there is
six or seven thousand languages spoken
in the world today and
it's hard to estimate very accurately
but you know most people would say
well over a hundred thousand languages
ever spoken
and
those languages are all products of
evolution on the the cultural historical
track
and i think the interesting questions
now are about the
as you suggested the kind of interplay
between those
where
human languages the ones that we speak
such as english we're speaking right now
or any of the other ones have
evolved historically and adapted to
the biological properties of
humans so you know things that are
relatively easy to learn
things that are relatively easy to
produce
uh things that give the best trade-off
between
effort and
you know reaching your goal and so on
those are the things that will be more
likely to
circulate so there's a really
strong interplay between that kind of
historical evolution or cultural
evolution track and
the biological wherewithal for
uh
understanding language and you know i
mean this is an open question but the
question that you really
started with you know are we have we
been changed because of language
i'm not sure if we can say just yet if
we've been biologically changed because
of language but
i mean certainly people would say yes in
terms of the vocal tract and so on but i
think that
the obvious answer to the question has
to do with
what society is like and with the fact
that we've just had this
unbelievable
revolution in social organization and
culture
around the world you know humans are
off the charts in terms of what any
species can do
you know we have science we have cities
we have
these amazing technologies and arguably
none of those things would be
possible without language so
you know in a sense the language has
changed us radically in so far as it's
created
um a world for us that we need language
to
to continue in so it's a kind of a niche
construction idea do we know if language
developed independently for different
groups or was there one
you know last universal common ancestor
of language like there are for
biological organisms
we don't know that there's certainly a
lot of discussion about that
there's controversy around the question
of whether
our
relatives neanderthals and other
species had language or not and
it's certainly not settled at all i
think received wisdom is that they
didn't um
but it's certainly being challenged
these days and
you know there's a lot of extrapolation
that has to go on so
obviously language itself doesn't
fossilize so you have to extrapolate
from
questions around um
you know what are the
what's the evidence of cultural
organization around
uh you know archaeological findings
uh also what's the evidence from
the anatomy
uh
you can sort of tell evidence about the
brain structure very you know it's very
sort of
inferential but just brain size or
cranial capacity and
a whole lot of elements that come into
these discussions but i think you know
in answer to your question it's
certainly there's no received uh
answer and
you know the question of whether all
existing languages are somehow descended
from a single proto language is
again in a certain sense unknowable
because we can't go back
that far in time but there's some really
interesting
work that's been done in recent decades
on language birth
in a sense so
in
some
situations in society where
so there's a few different contexts in
which you can get something that we
refer to as language birth and one of
them is
quite political
but certainly
linguistically very interesting and that
is the emergence of
languages out of
in colonial times with slave populations
you had people being brought together
who
came from many different language
communities and
you know these are the types of contexts
in which you get so called contact
languages
and what we now might call creoles
and those are languages that
are sort of
the words are often from a donor
language a european language such as
french or english
but the structure of the language kind
of grows over time
with the
uh first few generations so particularly
when children
learn the language they bring
structure to it uh new structure and
in within a couple of generations you
get a what used to be a kind of a
a simple contact language quite quickly
becoming
what we might call a fully fledged
language now
that is developed from
you know a vocabulary that's been
borrowed um
there's another type of language birth
that
is
fascinating which is the birth of
sign languages in communities of people
who are deaf
and hard of hearing
so
in a family setting you get
situations where a child is
deaf and so they won't acquire spoken
language in the same way
and you get what
are sometimes called home sign languages
or
there are other terms for them these are
systems of signs that
take on
uh some
firmly linguistic structures and they
grow
for practical purposes within homes and
oftentimes
you know they run a shortish course and
then you know
they don't need it anymore people move
and all of that but when you get a
concentration
of
deaf people within a community and
that's happened historically many times
where for example you have
a genetic high genetic incidence of
deafness within a small community or you
have
a lot of deaf people coming together in
a
in a city you know there's a deaf
schools pop up around the world and then
suddenly you have a critical mass
of people who are using
uh a language and in the case of deaf
scion you have quite a strong
tendency to draw on more iconic
representations
things that roughly look like what
they're representing
um
and yeah within a few generations again
you have a fully-fledged language coming
sort of out of nothing in a sense so
you know most languages aren't like that
most languages draw on
a historically developed language
that you can trace back in time
maybe a few thousand years um then
probably not beyond but there do exist
languages that are born a new in the
ways i've just described
yeah and this gets us on to what is more
about the subject of your book which is
the
not the give and take between our
biology and our languages but the give
and take between our way of perceiving
the world and our language right uh
maybe we maybe it's useful to go all the
way back to the old-fashioned superior
warf hypothesis that said that
the way that we conceptualize the world
is entirely in terms of our language and
i get the impression that this is
not completely true but also not
completely discarded
that's right the superior warf
hypothesis is
controversial and it's
extremely catchy you know people love it
and
the idea being that the language you
speak
changes your perception of the world or
alters your reality and it's been
because it is quite catchy it's been
understood
in
ways that are convenient to non-experts
or sort of fun for non-experts and
that's what has kind of circulated
around the world so for example you'll
hear it said that
uh a language is a prison for the mind
and you are locked in to your
interpretation of the world by the
language you speak and this is
a very strong hypothesis and it's not
something that sapir or wharf
ever said in so many words so
um edward sapir and benjamin lee wharf
they were linguists and anthropologists
of the first half of the 20th century
and
uh they
were
following the footsteps of france boaz
another anthropologist they were
fascinated by encountering languages
that had very surprising structures to
them so you know there was something
that they that wolf referred to as
standard average european the kind of
language that uh
you know standard average europeans
speak of course european languages are
different in many important ways but
there are many similarities and
their idea was oh
you know people in europe in europe uh
who have this sort of tradition of
thinking about language in in in written
terms that and they think about the
diversity of language as being
you know the difference between
russian and french and
english and
greek or something and they pointed out
you know you haven't seen half of it
this is a small amount of diversity uh
go to native america
and learn languages
like hopi or nutca the languages that
they were studying and
there you find that
the way in which reality is described
is very very different so there were
hypotheses about how time was understood
uh the way in which the language
described
time not as a
arrow but as a kind of cycle
and in fact
wharf found it difficult to articulate
the difference and this i think led to
the idea that oh you you know you can't
you can't understand the hopi world view
until you speak the language i i can't
simply explain it to you in english is
sort of part of the idea
so
there were interesting things that
are fascinating things that that wharf
and sapir
both laid out in terms of
just how languages are structurally
different
but what wharf
i think is
perhaps a bit more famous for is
his writing which is actually quite
limited but it's probably his most
famous writing
that comes out of his
work as an
insurance inspector so he worked for an
insurance company
and
was called out to
fires
to check them out and find out you know
what was the cause of the fire and
did the
uh
did the company you know were they
entitled to an insurance payout
so he looked at all these fire um
events and he he describes how he
believed that
the way in which people describe the
situations in their surroundings led to
certain behavior that would not have
arisen if they'd thought about or
described it in other ways
and it's pretty simple what he's arguing
so he's basically saying you know the
most famous example is the
fuel drums that
were
empty according to the
people who he spoke to in his
investigations
and he points out well yeah they didn't
have fuel in them but they were full of
fumes
and this was explosive and people were
careless with cigarettes and uh you know
a fire was started and he gives other
examples like
a substance called
spun limestone
which he says is also flammable and
people wouldn't think that because
the name of it has the word stone in it
and stone doesn't burn right so it's a
pretty it's a pretty straightforward
kind of claim that he's making
and i think
that the claims about wolf
being all about how your reality is
fundamentally different because of the
language you speak i mean
they're really rather exaggerated and in
a few places he may have spoken in those
ways i mean he did
but also a lot of the time he was being
much more concrete and
for me i think the most interesting part
of the claim is that
the language you speak
affects your reasoning
which in turn affects your behavior
but one thing i've tried to emphasize in
the book is something that he didn't
really pull out but it's in the work and
that is that we also use
language to explain what has happened to
explain why we've acted in the way we
have
and
to justify or to give an account
for what we've done and
that's exactly the context in which
wharf was
extracting these descriptions of you
know how fires started is that people
were
giving an account whoa well you know the
fire started um there was this spun
limestone and gosh who knows it was
gonna
go up in flames uh so i think that
points to my mind to something quite
overlooked in the literature on
all of this which we refer to as
linguistic relativity
and that is that you know it's not only
about cognition it's not only about
thought
it's just as much about social
coordination and about presenting
states of affairs
in a certain light
and particularly where you know that
presentation of states of affairs is is
in your interest or it aligns with what
you're trying to do and
one of those kinds of things would be
you know to defend your actions and and
that is where the the lawyer
comes in and you know it's the
metaphorical lawyer i have nothing
against lawyers
uh per se in in in that so and this is
exactly um
a crucial feature that shows up over and
over again not only in science but in
philosophy probably in other areas of
academia right where a lot of the work
you have to do
is seeing through the ambiguities that
are handed to you by your language right
the natural language that we invent to
get through the day is not up to the
task of discussing quantum mechanics or
metaphysics or what have you and what
you're saying in part is it was never
meant to be right that's not why we
invented and came up with language in
the first place
that's right it is
i mean
how we came up with language in the
first place is an interesting way of
putting it so going back to your
question about evolution
uh
the cognitive wherewithal for language
of course we didn't
invent that
modern languages are in a sense created
by people and they are a kind of
technology in that sense but
most of the time they're not invented by
people and
you know intentionally yeah so it's
quite interesting when you raise the
question about science because in
science we do coin words and we do
say oh here's a concept we don't have a
word for it so we better create this
word and here it is and then of course
we use
other words to define it
so
anytime we're creating a new bit of
language whether it's
on purpose like that or it's much more
sort of organic
new words pop up all the time in the
culture and you know no one really knows
who invented them
but they are being
built up through language
that already exist so for me to explain
to you what this new word means i i'm
gonna oftentimes be using words that
already exist in my language and
i think that of course that
puts a kind of bias on how our language
can develop
there's something that
people like
uh
wharf and sapir might have referred to
as world view
the kind of themes that permeate
throughout a language get reproduced in
some sense
partly because they align with our
cultural norms and and
and all of that
i think that one of the crucial
problems or sort of downsides of all of
this is that
once you have terminology even if you've
invented something that captures your
brand new specific concept that
no one knew about before
you are creating a sense in which people
become
satisfied with that label and satisfied
with that description
so in the book i
say that
words are off switches for the mind
and that's the sense in which i mean
that so
they
you know you do a kind of satisficing
you do a kind of
uh
shutting down of your reasoning
processes when you have
language that you're happy with simply
because
you know everything's going by so fast
we're
articulating language and processing
language at this great rate
and you don't want to be inspecting the
meanings of words for very long you
don't want to be
negotiating them of course you can
and we do but you certainly can't
negotiate every word as it flies past so
under all of those pressures
terminology whether it's everyday words
for objects or
scientific
terms
they will tend to bring about this kind
of i don't know something like a kind of
complacency in a way that you we all
kind of know what this means and we stop
talking about what it means but
under the surface do we really all have
the exact same understanding of it
well we don't
detect that a lot of the time and
the answer to that question really
depends on
the function of language and uh
you know i think that's one of the key
pieces in all of this is that
if i say to you something like
you know here's the keys to my car it's
in the parking lot uh can you bring it
around it's the red one
so
you don't have to know like what exact
shade of red it is as long as i'm
confident that it is
the one that is red as opposed to all
the other ones so there's a kind of
contrastive meaning and that indicates
that often
that's a piece of perceptual language it
describes a color
but it's just good enough for current
purposes
right so there's a real sense in which
uh you know language is optimized um and
that of course means that it only gets
good enough it doesn't get better than
that
uh and so the real answer to the
question is what do we actually use
language for
well yeah you mentioned in the book that
there are something like two million
distinct shades of color that we can in
principle
identify as human beings but no language
has two million words for colors and
so what you're doing is you're offering
an explanation for why that's true it's
because language has no purpose no
reason to be
that precise it would take effort it
would take brain power and cognitive
effort to be that precise without any
gain in functionality so it kind of
makes sense that language is doing well
enough without doing better
that's right it's a classic
trade-off as as you've just described it
you know it's it's going to be
diminishing returns very quickly the
more that we
distinguish
terms for colors
you can go into a
paint store and they might have 5 000
words for colors you know they have all
of these
labels technical terms
the ones i cite in the book i think
include aztec tan and
wing commander you can guess what colors
they are you can only guess um they're
highly specialized and in that context
the context of ordering paint
you do need to have quite a
quite a sort of high level of
granularity
but still and i think this is crucial
you are orders away from
the two million distinctions that you
just mentioned you know even the most
kind of
fine-grained
taxonomy of color that language can
handle is is
miles and miles from
what we can actually
perceive and i think it's also worth
emphasizing that
the color spectrum that we can perceive
is also
another massive number of orders away
from what's actually
out there that we could conceivably
perceive if we had different kind of
sensory
apparatus you know
and
that's a in the book i described this as
a kind of two-step
reduction in our experience of reality
so the first is
going from the
full catastrophe all
of reality that's out there we have this
radical reduction to just uh you know
for example the the visible uh
spectrum of light that that just that
section which is small
and then you have another radical
reduction down to
well i mentioned a few thousand in the
paint store example but in reality
no language in terms of the literature
on
color in languages no language is going
to have more than
a dozen
uh terms what are called
what are called basic color terms there
are oftentimes more specific terms like
scarlet or
alizarin but basic terms like red yellow
blue green those will be uh
fewer than a dozen and oftentimes just a
handful three or four or even fewer and
uh it turns out well those are good
enough for their purpose in
the cultural setting in which they have
historically evolved
and the
i i like that two-stage reduction that
goes on and it makes me bring up one of
my favorite topics here which is
emergence in the sense that this picture
that we construct of the world through
our language is much more coarse-grained
than the world itself is you know we're
not giving you all the details when we
describe the world and language
but it does well enough so we not only
are labeling the world in our language
but we're constructing a model of it
because like with the example you
already gave of going to get the red car
the reason why you can group together
relatively close colors of red under one
word is because it functionally
describes a world that we can then use
to manipulate and predict and so forth
so this is kind of an amazing feature
about the world that language can
describe it so compactly and efficiently
that's right and i think one thing i
want to add to that is that often
when we read particularly in the
cognitive science literature about
language the
the way of talking about it is
pretty much like the way you've just
spoken about it which is to do with
reasoning and
you know
reducing your
amount of processing and prediction
things like that
what is equally important or i think
actually more important is
the way in which these
categories are not just good enough for
thought
they have to be good enough what they
have to be good enough for is social
coordination right and so by that i mean
you know i might have a
an incredible
sensitivity to different colors in my
own personal vision
as we all do we walk around and we can
detect these differences but they don't
so that they are real for us and they're
part of our cognition and they're part
of what helps us navigate the world
they've been given to us by our
biological evolution and this is where
we come back to our evolutionary
question is that the categories in the
language
are not given to us by the biological
evolution
they're given to us by the cultural
evolution and what's crucial about that
is that words don't just spring directly
out of
patterns in our minds they don't spring
directly out of concepts that we have in
our head or percepts
they come from
instances of social coordination like
the example of me
telling you which car is mine uh that's
not an abstract
relation between me and a car it's
actually
what you might call a triatic
relation
yeah so there's me and there's you and
there's the car and the function of
language is to get us to align to
coordinate around
some bit of reality and language is our
little map for that it's our little
ticket for that you know
and
so it's job the categories of language
are being
focused on very heavily as being all
about
conceptualization and the mind which
clearly they are
but i think very
under discussed are the
the social payoffs and the
collaborative payoffs of those
categories and again it's not just in
for example directing a person to a
piece of reality that's one type of
action we do
but also very important is the kinds of
actions we do to as i mentioned earlier
in relation to wharf
we justify our actions
we try to convince people of what's the
right thing to do
we try to
persuade people of a certain analysis
and
the words that we choose
to do that are words that have succeeded
in the past
in our kind of cultural
milieu so
that i think is is is one of the crucial
things never to forget is that the
evolution of the words themselves
is
partly due to our cognition it has to be
but it's equally to do with our social
interactions yeah and this might be a
tiny bit of a detour but i was hoping
that you could explain
without using pictures this is an audio
only podcast but you give the example of
shelling's map
in the book which i'd never heard of
before but uh as an illustration of how
when we think as human beings
not only and you're completely right and
you're fair i was talking like a
physicist before describing the world
making a predictive theory of it but in
the social world we need to not only
understand the world and what it's going
to do but we need to have an image of
what's in other people's minds and this
shellings map example was a wonderful
[Music]
illustration of how we just use that
automatically it may be a way that is
even different between human beings and
other species
so shelling was an economist and
you know i think was most famous for
his book the strategy of conflict also
later uh the the uh macromotives the
microbehavior or is it the other way
around uh but in the early work on
conflict um
he
emphasized the
idea that you are
constantly trying to figure out what's
the other person gonna do
i'm going to
attack your village and
so you know you think i'll come
along the road so i won't go along the
road i'll come over the the hill but you
will have thought through that so you'll
expect me to come over the hill so i'll
come up in on the road and surprise you
you know so he was thinking through
the the psychology of of conflict and
that led him
to
realize that
actually the same kinds of operations
are crucial for cooperation as well
you are constantly trying to figure out
well
you know what is the other how does the
other person understand what's going on
here so
he had a lot of discussion of
little tests that he did with people
where
you ask them you put two people into two
separate rooms and you give them some
puzzle
and
the puzzle is
you tell them that there's someone in
the other room who's got the same puzzle
and if the two of you can solve it in
the same way then you know you've won
so one of the examples was the the map
that you just mentioned which was in in
in sherling's book
it was
uh map of a bit of terrain
and you were to imagine that you were a
parachutist who was coming down into
enemy territory
and another person was another
parachutist also coming into enemy
territory you both have the same map
you don't know where you've landed i
guess you know where you've landed you
don't know where the other person's
landed
and
where should you go
to meet each other so you don't get to
communicate beforehand all you can do is
think where will that person go
but not only that where would they go
thinking where will i go just from the
back and so that
just on the map so you're looking at the
map and you're thinking okay that person
knows i'm looking for them uh i know
they're looking for me we want to
converge where would we go
and the map happens to have a a bridge
in the center of the image and
that of course kind of skews the
solution a little bit um the fact that
there's kind of a bit of semiotics in
the map that points you to that spot but
you get the uh
the solution there are many others he
gives a long list of these other ones
another one that i mentioned in the book
is the
what's related to some of these kind of
tabletop economic games
you
put two people in two separate rooms
give them a hundred bucks
and you say
you know you split it in some way and
the other person in the other room is
going to split it in some way you both
know that you're splitting it in some
way if you split it the same way you get
to keep
the money according to that split
okay so if i go oh i'm going to split 60
40 and you say i'm going to split 50 50
we get nothing
and what happens is that people converge
much more often than you would expect by
chance on a 50 50 solution
so the upshot of the work on shellings
maps
or shellings coordination problems is
really how people refer to them is that
people are
well practiced and really quite good
at thinking through
how would i best coordinate with this
person on this problem i currently have
without being able to
talk about it with them beforehand and
this is the thing with language that
every time
we speak to someone you know we're in a
conversation and every couple of seconds
there's a new utterance being produced
you don't get to go back and say well
how are we going to understand the
meaning of this utterance right you just
have to
imagine
how do you
um how do people understand this and
that's the source of convention
it's a solution to these coordination
problems and so the problems that
shelling was talking about are ones
where you don't have a convention and
you don't get to communicate in advance
but the way that languages evolve over
time is that you know conventions emerge
precisely from repeated solutions to
these coordination problems
so if people have succeeded in
coordinating in a certain way they
will stick with that solution
right
so you get
in the book i talk about experiments
coordination experiments where for
example you give
a set of tangram figures to two people
and you know i have these ten tangram
figures in front of me and all of them
roughly have a kind of human form
and you're on
the other side of a barrier and i'm told
that you have these figures in front of
you and i have to tell you what order to
lay them out in so i have to use
language to get you to identify which
figure i'm talking about
so
there's
one figure that
people when they look at it they often
say it looks kind of like a
ice skater and it's got its
feet sticking
up and leaning over and yeah people give
quite sort of long descriptions the
first time around and when you get
people to repeat the task the same pair
of people just do it over and over again
within five or six times they just have
created a vocabulary to refer to these
figures so that they quickly just
instead of having this long description
they just say
the ice skater
so
the creation of
convention is really very quick
and the reason is of course that it has
this great payoff that you just
suddenly no longer have to spend all
this effort talking and processing
language you just go straight to the the
label and people can uh fulfill the task
is the way in which people have
an image of someone else's way of
thinking uh that happens in these
coordination problems how culturally
different is it uh we had herbert
guintas on the podcast and he talked
about you know doing game theory
experiments or economics experiments in
different cultures and getting different
kinds of answers do you think that the
shelling that problem would be equally
solved by anyone from two different
cultures
no i don't so
it really depends on i mentioned the
term common ground and
there are different types of common
ground so the psychologist herb clark
has written a lot about this and indeed
also about the shelling games that the
tangram uh task was was by him and and a
student um
he points out that
common ground can be
personal so you have common experiences
with
people who you know with family members
and friends and
you can invoke that common experience
through
kind of elliptical references and
nods and winks and that kind of thing
you you draw on
your common ground your common knowledge
with people to
sort of minimize the effort you have to
go to to communicate and that's at a
personal level we recognize that but
then there's this higher level which is
cultural common ground
and that is
of course it includes the
all the words in the language it also
includes this whole set of kind of
cultural
knowledge
whether it has to do with sports or food
or the way people behave in
shops and on buses and you know it's a
this is what anthropologists study it
goes on and on and on just to get
through your day you're drawing on this
incredible amount of
cultural common ground so the
coordination problems that are being
solved
through things like getting on buses and
ordering food and
these kinds of things
are all drawing on what's called
cultural common ground and
we don't really appreciate
and humans have to learn and learn and
learn for years as as children and as
young people
what all of that common ground is in the
society that they're living in
so the answer to your question is that
because cultures
are very different in terms of their
their contents
it means that
no you can't just assume that other
people in another culture share all of
that common ground and this is the
essence of
cross-cultural miscommunications that
we've all experienced in different
countries
now that's not to say that there aren't
some core commonalities in
human society and human thought and and
that is part of the
goal of cognitive science and of the
anthropological component of that
we do expect because we're all the same
species that there are going to be
certain commonalities but the question
is whether those commonalities come from
sort of directly from our
biology or
secondarily from our biology what i mean
by that is
in the sense
of
all being subject to the
force of gravity and all having human
bodies that
you know sneeze or whatever uh there's
certain commonalities that we have
and
the question then is well
is it because of that commonality that
they that though certain concepts
inevitably arise in every single culture
i think that is
the likely answer
because it's only through being used in
social
interaction
can these concepts find their way into
the language so you're never going to
get a direct link from the biology to
the language that you actually speak
that always has to be
delivered through
a history of successful solutions to
coordination problems using the
resources of the language yeah and it
seems from examples you quote in the
book that there is a lot of commonality
it seems to me as an outsider there's a
lot of commonality in language um but
there will be cultural differences in
how we carve up the world into different
pieces right one of the examples you
talk about is just parts of the body
right like uh japanese and dutch will
label you know the different parts of
the body slightly differently and as
long as they agree within their language
community that makes perfect sense
that's right and the question is
is that
variation unconstrained you know the
what we find is what i refer to in the
book as a kind of constrained diversity
and a lot of linguistics has been about
trying to
determine just what that is
or what the nature of that is so a field
of linguistics called linguistic
typology is all about sort of trying to
find out what is universal to language
what is likely to happen in language
if a language has a certain property
what other properties will it also have
so the kinds of things i talk about in
the book
are in the kind of semantic
domain and they have to do with you know
if a language has
let's say i don't know three
color terms what are they going to be
and it turns out we can predict fairly
well
what kind of order a language will begin
to sort of make distinctions and so you
can't say beforehand whether a language
will have three color terms or 12 color
terms but if it has x number
then there's something about the way in
which
those systems evolve
that allows us to see some kind of um
some kind of regularity so a lot of sets
of semantic distinctions differ just in
terms of the number of distinctions that
they make
and the question then becomes well what
drives that
distinction what drives the fact that
language x has more distinctions in
language y has fewer
but also what kind of regularities do we
see in the way that the space gets
carved up so i think the
crucial thing to take away from this is
that
nobody would say nowadays anything goes
in a language so you wouldn't have a
color term a color system in a language
that has
12 words for shades of red
and one word for every other color it's
just not gonna this is just never works
like that so you get the space being
carved up in in certain sensible ways
and again it comes back to functionality
and
uh what
is
useful in terms of coordination so you
might predict for example that
you live in a place that has a certain
kinds of ochre and you use those kinds
of ochre for coloration of the body or
of clothing or painting on stone
and you would predict that yes at a
certain level you you'd get a special
vocabulary for
shades of red
you'd also predict that that would stand
alongside a color system that would
flesh out the rest of the color spaces
just as well
and so this is where it gets a little
bit heavy i think um heavy in the sense
of difficult and interesting but also
significant and important um
if we do carve up the world um both in
how we perceive it and then how we
codified into language does that have a
sort of back reaction on what we see
when we look at the world and how we
think about it does it introduce biases
or
flaws that are inevitably there because
of the way that we think about things
linguistically
yes i think it does and i talk about
some of the ways in which that happens
so one is
in the cognitive realm um
for the reasons that we've been
discussing
having certain structures in your
language determines what you
will kind of be less likely to question
you know what are the descriptions that
you'll be satisfied with what are the
ways of talking that will cause you not
to want to inspect reality any more
closely you know what are the what are
the resources that will make you shut
off your thinking in some sense so you
definitely see that
experimentally
there's been interesting work which i
talk about in the book
some of these studies of by lara
boradicki and colleagues
that look at
kind of tap into that but they do so by
looking at people's
judgments
so
an example of this is
you show people
a
scenario of somebody
at a restaurant there's a candle on the
table
they get up from their seat and
the tablecloth is tangled up in their
clothes and
then you tell one group in the
experiment um you know she knocked over
the candle and
she started a fire
and you tell another group an experiment
you know the candle toppled and a fire
started so one of those ex one of those
descriptions is kind of
agentive and
another description is is not agentive
and it turns out that people depending
on how you describe it
even though what they see is the same
they will
make different kinds of judgments
they'll they will in this case they will
literally
suggest different
amounts of money that the person should
be fined for the damage that they caused
in the restaurant right
so
what's interesting about those examples
is that they
mix
something to do with reasoning and
decision making with something that is
much more social which has to do with
the giving of reasons for
certain judgments that you make so for
every judgment that there is
you're not just making the judgment in
your head you're you're using the
judgment for some social purpose and in
that case you're using the judgment
uh you know to to
as a reason for why you've for example
um
decided to find this person that much
money so in that case
the reason that you're giving is
actually provided by the experimenter so
the experimenter controlled that the
experimental in one case it used the
active way of talking about it and in
the other case the the more passive way
now there are linguistic differences
here because
some languages so in that case japanese
is a contrast language because
it it allows you to be relatively
uh
agentive or relatively kind of passive
in how you describe scenes but
it has a much more of an emphasis
towards a kind of a non-agentive
depiction of events and
so that actually correlates with
different people's
judgments about those kinds of scenarios
that people will understand the outcomes
to have been
less agentive and less the
responsibility or less caused by the
person who is there
as an agent so those things kind of
bleed into
social justifications and that's a kind
of a lawyerish
element of language
i think there are some really
interesting other cases that i talk
about in the book one i might just
mention is the
is a study of
emergency calls in a
cardiac
emergency ambulance unit so this is at a
hospital in perth
western australia
and the call takers were given an
instruction at the beginning of the call
they get the person's name and location
and then they ask tell me exactly what
happened
and then you know the person whose
loved one is
lying on the floor it goes into a kind
of a
a little narrative about what led to the
situation but some of the call takers
without being prompted to do so they
they gave a very slightly different
wording instead of saying tell me
exactly what happened they said tell me
exactly what's happened so they add the
little s to what
and you know in english that's a
difference between what you would call a
simple past
you know what happened versus a what's
happened is it what's called a present
perfect
and that second
way of putting it focuses on what is the
situation now whereas the first way of
putting it
focuses on what led to it so this
actually has a direct impact on how
people then respond to the question so
if you ask what happened they will give
a narrative if you ask what's happened
they will describe what's currently the
case and this study found that
that response which is completely
linguistically
conditioned
led to differences in the you know
average differences in the time it took
to get an ambulance dispatch to to go
and deal with the emergency
now it's not a lot of time difference
but you know when you're lying on the
floor and cardiac arrest it's you kind
of want things to move along pretty
quickly so i mean answer to your
question i think
that kind of example shows that the
choice of words has this
obviously great consequence for how
people
reason and respond and we assume that
their behavioral response is kind of a
result of their
their reasoning
but one of the key things to remember
here is that not all languages have
those same distinctions
you know that little tense distinction
uh that i
pointed to with english is not present
in all languages and other languages
have different ways of carving up the
space of how we talk about time just as
we have for talking about color
so over and over again through the
thousands of words that you have in in
the vocabulary of your language
you're
setting up this kind of space for
nudging people this way and that
in terms of not just how their reason
but i think more importantly how they
act and how they
act upon their reasoning uh in the real
world it's fascinating because it makes
me think of a recent podcast i did with
judea pearl who
studies causality um from a sort of
network of random variables kind of
perspective and a big part of his
research is helping artificial
intelligence understand causal
relationships between things but i have
the impression that
that teaching ai had a reason causally
is entirely in terms of physically what
happens
and what you're mentioning is that when
we human beings do it we have this other
layer of social meaning right that
assigns
blame or responsibility based on an
entirely different set of factors than
the computer might even be aware of
yeah i agree and i think i mean
causality is really
an interesting case
oftentimes people will
acknowledge that
you know causality is really an
interpretation
of a relationship between two things and
you could also say it's a description
and why would you describe causes well
very often causes are about
justifications or giving reasons now why
do humans give reasons they give reasons
because
they're trying to
justify or defend or you know rally
others into some kind of action so
there's a you know i think it's really
crucial not to just focus on an abstract
relation between two events or two
states of affairs but linguistically
why would anyone ever talk about a cause
well it's typically for these social
reasons so i think it's really
interesting what you raise about
explainable ai that that term is often
used
in
the press and in the literature these
days is quite a concern with explainable
ai and i find it fascinating because
you're told
that ai
can't come up with
explanations for why it's made certain
decisions so let's say it's denied your
parole application you know a
machine learning algorithm has denied
your parole application we can't
understand why this is and in fact the
algorithm cannot
tell us why and no human can understand
why they just know what they put in and
look this is what came out
now
what's interesting there is that when
you
the implication is that humans giving
explanations
is adequate
the humans giving explanations is
acceptable
and you know i find that wild because
humans give all sorts of crazy
explanations for what they do which
seldom i don't know about seldom but
often don't
have much relation to what's really gone
on do they really understand
why they came to the decision they came
to are they letting on
uh you know so to my mind
you might want to explain a human
decision in terms of
the neurons that fired
but that's equally impossible to
understand as as uh you know the
performance of a deep learning algorithm
so i always
worry about this kind of demand that we
want explainable ai
insofar as it implies that human
explanations are perfectly fine
whereas
they're not a lot of the time and and
the real measure is not what's the
quality of the explanation but do people
accept it and move on yeah and
i think that's
you know the language people use
plays a very important role in whether
others will accept their explanations
and move on yeah and and this is we're
getting into the the constraints and the
foibles or fallibilities that are uh
engendered by our use of language and
another one that you mentioned in the
book which is maybe related
is how
it overwrites our memories right like
we'll see something we'll have a picture
of what happened then we'll talk about
it and we remember if i'm getting this
right we remember
our verbalization of it
more than we remember what we saw the
first time around
that's right it's a little bit different
to to what you describe
a bit basically i think that's right so
there are several different
experiments that i talk about that kind
of touch on this
going
earlier into the
20th century so first half of the 20th
century there were some
really nice studies of
getting people to reproduce little
abstract line drawings so you would show
people a little line drawing
you'd ask them to remember exactly what
they see
later on you'd have them
draw what they saw
with a pencil on paper
and
early on
this was all that the task involved but
people
experimenters noticed that people were
often giving some kind of commentary so
they would say
this is a bit like with the tangram
experiment uh people would be drawing
this little drawing and they'd say oh
yeah it's it's like a star or oh it's
like a bird or oh it's like eyeglasses
and they would use this
verbalization to
describe what they've seen and then
experimenters thought well hang on maybe
people are using those verbalizations to
you know as aids to help them to
remember
and
so
various experiments were then done and
where people were primed with different
descriptions of the exact same drawing
so you can take a drawing that has two
circles next to each other and a little
line in between them with a slight bend
and you give one group
the instruction or you just put a label
on the drawing these are eyeglasses and
with the other group it's exact same
drawing you give a label that says
dumbbell
and
later when you get people to redraw
these
the ones who were primed with the word
eyeglasses will
make that band in the line a bit more
pronounced you know that's where the
eyeglasses hang on your nose and the
other group who were told yeah this is a
dumbbell would make the line straighter
than it was in the original drawing you
know so
they're clearly being
affected by the way in which language
had kind of
got them to construe what they were
seeing even though they were told
not to think about the language but to
just focus directly on the on the
drawing so the the way in which people
describe things will affect
their memory in those ways the
overshadowing effect i'm not sure if you
mentioned that term but from the section
where i talk about this in the book
there's more recent work about verbal
overshadowing
which is
similar but it emphasizes the idea of
kind of
discarding information because of
language so
experiments would include
seeing a
robbery bank robbery you watch a video
of a bank robbery and you see the
perpetrator's face
and
with one group of people in the
experiment you're asked to describe the
purpose traders face as accurately as
you can and another group of
people in the experiment are given some
other tasks they're not given an
opportunity to talk about the
perpetrators face at all so they don't
kind of
um
they don't use language to to talk about
it and then later when you give people
the chance to identify the face in a
lineup of faces
the people who described the face with
words are worse at identifying the face
that they saw yeah and
and there's been really interesting
follow-up cases of that one i
particularly like is looking at a
uh a catalog from a furniture store and
you
have to
in the task you just see lamps and
chairs
and you just have to press a button if
it's a lamp you press a button on the
left it's got lamp written on it and if
it's a chair you press a button on the
right that has chair written on it
and that's one group of people in the
task another group of people don't have
to sort them as lamps and chairs
they just say something like do they
like them or do they not like them
would they want them in their home or
not some other kind of question
and it turns out the ones who sort them
in terms of the linguistic categories
that are available then later if you
show them
more pictures
and you ask them did in in the earlier
phase of the experiment did you see this
exact
lamp or did you see this exact chair
the ones who were sorting are worse at
doing this task
and
the argument there is essentially
grounded in the concept of
categorization which is you know
grouping things together and throwing
away
all the differences between them
so we haven't really talked about this
but language is this massive collection
of categories you know words for objects
words for actions all of these things
just throw together really very
varied bits of reality
and group them together for the purpose
of
coordination precisely because yeah the
differences don't really make a
difference for the tasks that we use
these words for in everyday life
so
you know we don't
usually have to solve those experiments
in normal life and of course you know
psychology experiments are always
pushing the boundaries of what we can do
and these show that yeah there are these
foibles and these downsides but clearly
from an evolutionary perspective they
were never
enough to get
uh
weeded out
yeah so uh
if i have thought about these images as
lamps or tables that's what i remember i
do not remember the details as well as
if i were just looking them as images
that's right and this seems like
not to get too dark but maybe this is
you know one of the punch lines of your
book that
these are all handles with which other
people can be manipulated or manipulate
us or we can manipulate others in some
sense right uh the fact that
language serves this social function
gives us ways of not merely describing
what is going on but
layering the descriptions with
slightly normative or judgmental
feelings about it and
it seems like this is again a universal
feature of different kinds of languages
absolutely and it's not slightly
normative it's
entirely nominated i would say um
so i subscribed to the krebs and dawkins
theory of
communication so
krebs and dawkins did a paper in the
1980s
on
the nature of
animal communication and the whole idea
of that was that
it's not about
conveying information it's about acting
upon others
it's about influencing others
and so
you know instead of
walking up to someone and dragging them
into a room
you say come inside
you know and so what you're doing is
acting upon them through
using
sound or whatever other medium your
language uses
and
they then as krebs and dawkins put it
you what you're doing is exploiting
their muscle power
for you to uh to somehow benefit and
with of course a very important caveat
that that benefit is typically mutual
benefit that's what we want to
mean by coordination
so that's why i'd say
it's not too dark
you know we shouldn't be thinking of
this as a as a kind of a dark view you
easily can
if you focus on language as manipulative
and and you know all about influence and
so on but it's just the nature of
communication in a world of
mobile agents you know you are trying to
align you're trying to coordinate
whether it's this is self-interested or
kind of group interested or even
altruistic
you're still
getting things done by acting upon
the other
in such a way that you then get them to
initiate some either some action or some
understanding uh or what have you and i
think that
this is yet another way in which i'm
trying to move the focus from thinking
about
meaning in language as being this thing
in the head and this thing to do with
imagery and reasoning and so on but more
about
action in in in the social world and
kind of public events of acting upon
others and then repeatedly
getting some
roughly predictable kind of responses
from them which then help to condition
you know the
uh stabilization of words within a
population and the conventionalization
and so on so again that the whole thing
kind of circles back to
what have we used words for in the past
and you know they should be for mutual
benefit so i'm quite happy to be
influenced by other people if this is
part of
what we do
and
you know the life that we lead together
i'm i'm happy to be influenced by others
a lot of the time and i think part of i
should also say that
i do think the book gets pretty dark in
some places because
a lot of the time we are highly
vulnerable to being exploited in ways
that actually we don't want to be
so a lot of the
kind of nudging that language does
is
outside of our awareness
we're typically
not questioning the way that our
language is put together we're typically
not questioning the
ways in which people frame the things
that they say and so
this demands
a certain degree of mindfulness and it's
tough right because you've got to get
the balance between
thinking carefully about why did this
person say this in that way
on the one hand but on the other hand
you know you just want to get through a
conversation you just want to get the
thing done that you're trying to get
done
and
so yeah it's it's really about kind of
being mindful and and
thinking critically about what's
happening in language in some moderation
you know one of my previous guests was
julia galliff whose specialty is just
trying to think rationally and one of
the things she she says is that if she
reads a newspaper report or something
like that uh that quote someone and said
and
the article says this person admitted
that the following thing happened she
just translates that into her brain into
this person said that the following
thing happened because the word admitted
you know adds on this extra layer of and
it was against their interests or
something like that which maybe is
cheating or i mean maybe it's just true
but anyway thinking about it in a more
value neutral way might give us a better
more accurate perspective on it
yeah i'm a big fan of julia gailiff and
you know i think that the
contrast in
the book we're talking about between
lawyers and scientists is very much akin
to the one that she's set up between
scouts and
soldiers or the other way around that
you know the soldiers are the lawyers
who have a
it's something they want to defend and
uh the scouts of the scientists who are
trying to
discover the truth and you know i think
that
her approach
that particular example i think is
is exactly the kind of thing that we
ought to be doing particularly when
we're
reading
news reports and we're looking at social
media and and so on
precisely for the reasons that you just
suggested so those are good cases where
a little bit of selective language use
is introducing these worlds of
understanding that you just kind of have
to accept as they fly past
and you know semanticists if you look at
a verb like admit so one of my old
professors anna vishbitska at the
australian national university
she wrote a book uh called english
speech act verbs
so this refers to you know verbs in
english that refer to
things that we do by speaking so
it would be things like admit and say
and
tell and instruct and all of the words
in fact it's an entire book just about
you know fleshing out the semantics of
these
of these speech act verbs there's a lot
of them in english
and what's amazing is that you know for
everyone there's a couple of pages of
deep
complex explication and and so just by
saying a word like admit as opposed to
say
you really are bringing in this whole
kind of
schema this whole kind of world of
understanding and and you you touched on
it
when you said you know
saying something that's
perhaps against their will or
incriminating towards them and and this
kind of thing so
so i completely agree with that strategy
and i think that is an essential part of
the kind of cognitive literacy and
that we need in this day and age
if only people were
more critical and precisely that way
i think we'd all be
we'd all be better off and but what i
really value about that type of approach
is it's very concrete and it says okay
well when that happens here's a step
that you could take
and what i find interesting about that
particular example is that
when you translate admit
and to say
what you're doing is you're stepping
to a different level of granularity
the language is very hierarchical right
so say is a is a very general term
that's going to be semantically
quite underspecified for all of those
bits of meaning that you get at that
at that more granular level so the step
from admit to say is not just a random
step it's specifically a step from from
one level in the taxonomy of semantic
specificity to
another level and then that makes it
i think a less certainly a less
prejudging level at which you can try to
evaluate what's being said based on its
content rather than the framing that in
this case the journalist gives it
and maybe uh you know to wind things up
this might be may or may not be a good
thing to do so you you can tell me but i
kind of feel like we should
give some credit to the lawyers not just
to the scientists like the fact that we
use language not just to accurately
describe the world but to persuade
people or to advocate for certain
positions is not entirely a flaw or not
even at all of law it is part of what we
need to do and want to do um we want to
persuade people of our
political side we want to persuade
people to
take collective action for the
betterment of the world and so forth uh
we want to let people know how we feel
about them and all these other
non-descriptive things uh
what does the what is the kinds of
insights into language and its origins
as social communication
uh tell us about that those aspects of
language you know how
what is the what are the good side of
being a lawyer or an advocate i think
the things you've just mentioned
indicate that
or the way in which we want to
understand the things you've just
mentioned is to say that
these
lawyerly
aspects of language are features not
bugs
i would want to say that
you know this is in line with with work
on on reasoning more generally by dan
sperber and hugo mercier recently in a
couple of books
where they've said look you know
reasoning is supposedly flawed
uh we have all these cognitive biases
but if you think
about them not as
mechanisms for arriving at the truth but
rather things like ways to construct
convincing justifications
then the whole thing makes sense and i
think with language it's the same thing
so i definitely don't want to be saying
that you know
the the lawyer approach is is is bad in
some intrinsic sense quite quite the
opposite you know this is precisely what
language is for and in my view
the fact that you can kind of speak
scientifically about language that's
more the epi phenomenon that's more
the sort of exactation that we've done
and we've gone oh my god you know we can
use language
to do this
other thing this we can use it to
coordinate
around
new truths and we can use it to kind of
get together to find out new facts and
that's a great payoff but i think
fundamentally certainly most of what we
use language for is is precisely for all
of those functions of of persuasion and
so on
i think one thing that's really
important to to say here is that
there is inevitably a conflict
i mean not inevitably not in every case
there's oftentimes there's there's no
conflict between
the truth and what we're trying to
convince people of but i don't think
there's a necessary alignment obviously
there isn't a necessary alignment so if
you happen to be a wonderful storyteller
if you happen to be a wonderful
wordsmith
that's great you know you'll convince
people of stuff but how do i know that
you have the truth how do i know that
the thing you're trying to convince me
of is really
true is really correct well oftentimes
it doesn't maybe matter that much
it all really depends on what this is
about but
as you know
certainly better than i
you want to get at the truth because
knowing the truth has these
untold consequences you know if you're
going to design
technology that will
send us to the
you know second lagrange point or what
have you
uh
you're not gonna do that just by being
the better storyteller right we don't
want to just have the better storyteller
maybe we want a great storyteller in
certain contexts so for example if we're
trying to get
the
government to give us
billions of dollars to to make that
happen then you know maybe in that
context yeah you want a great lawyer a
great
uh
soldier a great storyteller
but you you want to be sure that the
that the truth is getting a look in
right
and that's the key so i i do think
there's a really interesting ethical
question there and that is that you know
you any
lawyer
in in this metaphorical sense that we're
exploring here you know really has an
ethical duty not to be trying to
convince people of falsehoods
and
so the the lawyer and the scientists
need to be working together and to my
mind
you know ultimately the lawyer is
accountable to the scientist because
if we get reality wrong we die
i mean yeah i'm not going to disagree
with anything you just said it does make
me think a little bit about the history
of lysenko-ism in the soviet union where
they came up with a version of biology
that was more flattering to the uh
government
and it can't last right because you
can't fool your way you can't tell a
better story about biology that is in
conflict with the truth
that's right so it also reminds me of
solzhenitsyn's book the first circle
where you have in fact these are
linguists
in
the first circle of hell namely the sort
of
least
worst uh
re-education camps in the gulags and
they were
supposed to come up with speech
technologies that could uh
you know do what whatsapp does these
days but
you know um
co code your your speech and not be uh
vulnerable to spies and all that kind of
thing and in the book the the scientists
are saying oh yes yes we're nearly ready
with the uh with the device you know
we're just doing a few last kind of
tweaks but of course they had no idea
how to do this thing that
stalin demanded to be done and and they
were just stalling for time the entire
time
um so the you know literally whether
they lived
another day all came down to sort of how
convincing they were as to the progress
of this technology but but but in the
end of course
uh you know it's not gonna it's not
gonna work out you know the real world
does provide even language with
constraints that it cannot completely
work around that that's a good lesson so
nick enfield thanks so much for very
informative podcast here
thanks very much for having me
[Music]
so
[Music]
you